رفضت الاداره الامريكيه التصريحات الاخيره
للوزيرين الاسرائيليين بتريل سموتريتش
وتمار بن كفير الداعيه الى اعاده توطين
الفلسطينيين خارج غزه ووصفت الخارجيه
الامريكيه مثل هذا الخطاب بالتحريض وغير
المسؤول داعيه الى وقفه فورا واضافت ان
موقف واشنطن واضح لا لبس فيه بان غزه ارض
فلسطينيه وستظل ارضا فلسطينيه مع عدم
سيطره حماس على مستقبلها وعدم وجود جماعات
ارهابيه قادره على تهديد امن
اسرائيل من جهته قال وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي تمار بن جفير ردا على تصريحات
مسؤول امريكي ان اسرائيل ليست نجمه اخرى
في العالم الامريكي واضاف ان الولايات
المتحده صديقه لبلاده ولكن في نهايه الامر
سيفعل الاسرائيليون ما هو جيد لهم واوضح
ان هجره مئات الاف الفلسطينيين من غزه
ستتيح لسكان الغلاف العوده والعيش في
وستحمل الجيش
الاسرائيلي